it's good to see you guys again nice to
meet you yeah yeah how are you doing
congratulations very very well because
this season is excellent yet again you
guys are awesome all right i'm going
full spoilers here so you could talk
freely and we will run it after the
season comes out nice
jacob i'm coming your way first with
probably a too complicated question here
because i have like a million things to
ask about the hawk but i'll go into
carter first what was your reaction to
first finding out that hawk would lose
the hawk and then
is there anything about losing the hawk
and the way that he carried himself
before that gave you access to something
new in the character that you didn't
even realize was there before
yeah so
um losing the hawk was something they
had
first joked about like in season one or
two of like oh yeah that'd be kind of
cool to see what happens like you know
he's super cool because of his mohawk
what would happen if he lost it um and
then season three came around and
they're like yeah you know
we're thinking maybe season five we'll
do could do the mohawk or whatever i was
like oh okay and then season four came
out they're like yeah we're doing it
we're doing it this season and i'm like
oh shoot
it felt like it came so suddenly um
and i i was pretty bummed i was like oh
man but that's my thing like i like it
um
so i was a little bummed but i it really
did open up new um parts of the
character because it was totally like
you know what is king arthur without a
sword type thing um
and it was fun to get to explore that
and sort of
um dive into
uh being eli again and
just having
really good people around him like you
know dimitri the binary brother uh there
to pick him up and the good influence of
johnny and daniel they're uh picking
them up uh but yeah it was it was really
fun to get to be eli and feel okay as
eli gianni for you
i feel like all of the main characters
on the show have kind of turned to the
dark side to a degree with their karate
at one point or another but not dimitri
and i know we don't really know all that
much about his background and his home
life at this point but for you what
quality of dimitri and things going on
off screen that we don't get to see do
you think contributes to him being able
to keep control and never let the anger
take over
uh i like to think um you know dimitri
has always been kind of this nerdy sort
of character and uh i
created a background for him in kind of
a family home life uh to kind of justify
some of the things that demetri does
um just kind of like parents that you
know really instilled hey don't be a
bully you know that's important and um
yeah i just kind of think it's cool that
dimitri has always been this nerd and
he's never really compromised um
going to the dark side even though he's
had many opportunities to
join cobra kai even though it's you know
one resulted in him getting flipped and
then another time getting his nose
broken but
yeah
yeah dimitri will never be a dark sided
individual i don't know
i know i know i it's not gonna be canon
in the show but can you share any
details about the backstory that you've
personally come up with that's kind of
helped serve as a guiding light for you
throughout the show
yeah i always get nervous sharing it
because then i don't want it to be like
later on the writers be like no that's
not what it is at all i'm like i'm sorry
i'm working with what i have you know he
only just got a last name in uh season
four
oh yeah yeah he only just got last name
but we we still don't know his uh home
life but i agree imagine
what yeah he's great
i have a greek note so it works why not
um
but i kind of like to imagine his home
life is maybe it's a like a single mom
that's kind of a paralegal or something
like that so she's she's pretty smart
but she doesn't have like a lot of time
to be around and that's how i kind of
justify you know her not being at the
tournament or
being there when he breaks his arm
because i feel like that would be a big
thing but um yeah
an interesting thing to consider i
appreciate you sharing that all right
cholo i think
by far one of the most effective
performance beats in the entire season
is your reaction to drunk johnny in
episode 8
particularly the extreme emotional
rollercoaster of it because
he he feels like the two
most extreme responses based on what
johnny says in that beat so
is something like that especially
challenging for you and how do you
prepare yourself to go on that emotional
journey in one single scene
yeah uh that was a that was i mean
honestly those types of scenes are my
favorite ones to film especially with
billy like i feel like we've kind of had
one of those every season like we had
you know the one in that burger shop in
the second season we had we had actually
a few this this fourth season but
you know i think when it comes down to
it
you i
what
gives me the most comfort is knowing
that like at the core miguel wants to
make johnny proud and especially in
season four how we see this new aspect
getting involved of like this you know
it always was kind of like an unsaid
fatherly figure but now that
you know johnny's getting busy with my
mom like now it really is like a father
figure
and
it i think that regardless as to whether
or not it's said does add like a new
layer of responsibility for johnny and i
think that's kind of what just makes it
so much more heartbreaking from a girl
when he's like finally the words i've
been waiting for all these years are
followed by like
i hate the guy like yeah yeah no not
even like i not even like anger because
i don't think it's angry i think it's
just like oh man like
it's it's not me like it's it's not it's
and that that was a really fun day
though that was a really good one and
and billy gave a really great
performance too in that scene like
that's it was it's it's hard to see
billy look like that because he's like
not
at all like a drunk or anything like
that in real life so it's funny just
seeing them flip that flip that switch
but those that was a really fun day and
and uh it was a little bit hard but
honestly i don't um
i
like after stuff like that happens you
kind of just gotta all right let's move
on to the next day you can't you can't
get too focused on it otherwise you'll
just be like oh man this sucks every oh
like these scenes are way too hard but
uh but uh no it was a great day i'm glad
to hear you call it fun because i was
emotionally exhausted after that scene
but i love the season so much you guys
know how much i love the show huge
congratulations yet again and until
season five
thank you it's nice to see you again
perry you too have a good one guys
thanks again